Musique légère
-Ce matin-là,
la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale a pris place
dans un train direction Dijon,
à 300 km du palais Bourbon.
-Je considère
que quand on fait
de la politique,
on le fait avant tout
pour les gens et avec les gens.
Donc, aller à la rencontre
des Français,
quels que soient le moment
et les circonstances,
pour moi,
c'est vraiment un impératif.
Etre à portée, à proximité,
c'est pour ça qu'on fait
de la politique.
Il ne faut pas avoir peur
de la confrontation, du débat,
il ne faut pas avoir peur
de la critique, parfois.
Et donc, c'est mon 20e
ou 21e déplacement
depuis que je suis élue.
-A Fontaine-Française,
Yaël Braun-Pivet
vient inaugurer
un nouveau réseau de chaleur
pour ce village
de 800 habitants.
-On vous accueille
avec beaucoup de plaisir.
-Bravo.
-Comme à chaque déplacement,
elle en profite
pour savoir ce que l'on pense
de son institution.
-Juste un verre d'eau.
Je vais être très raisonnable.
-Je suis maire d'un village.
-De combien d'habitants ?
-139. On vient de recenser.
-Et vous, maire de combien ?
-100 habitants.
-L'Assemblée,
vous en pensez quoi ?
-Tout est compliqué.
-Vous voudriez pas être députée
ou à ma place ?
-Je vous rassure,
c'est pas toujours comme ça.
Parfois, c'est le bazar,
mais la plupart du temps,
ça ne l'est pas.
-Puis, il y a le passage obligé
devant la presse locale.
La présidente de l'Assemblée
est au centre de l'attention.
Dans les prochains jours,
elle doit rendre une décision
sur la proposition de loi LIOT,
qui veut abroger
la réforme des retraites,
une décision qui pourrait
être très contestée.
-On est partis !
Comme à l'Assemblée !
Bonjour, la séance est ouverte.
-Sur la semaine à venir,
comment vous abordez jeudi,
notamment ?
-Je l'aborde très sereinement.
Moi, ma boussole,
c'est l'institution
que j'ai l'honneur de présider
et l'application
de nos règles communes.
L'Assemblée nationale
est le lieu du débat organisé
et je m'efforce, au quotidien,
de m'assurer que ce débat organisé
puisse avoir lieu selon les règles
qui ont été définies
par d'autres que nous, avant nous,
et qui subsisteront après nous.
Je vous remercie.
-Merci.
-En Côte-d'Or comme ailleurs,
la contestation contre la réforme
des retraites est toujours vive.
Pour la deuxième étape
de son déplacement,
Yaël Braun-Pivet a droit
à un comité d'accueil,
des militants de la CGT
et leurs casseroles.
Les députés qui l'accompagnent
hésitent un peu,
mais pas Yaël Braun-Pivet.
Raffut de casseroles
...
-Merci beaucoup.
Bonjour.
Bonjour, monsieur.
Vous allez bien ?
-Non, ça va pas. Ca va pas du tout.
-Bon. Monsieur.
-Mme la présidente, bonjour.
-Bonjour, monsieur.
Bonjour, madame. Bonjour.
Vous voulez bien me serrer la main ?
Bonjour. Bonjour, madame.
Monsieur, bonjour.
Monsieur...
-J'ai été bien élevé, vous savez.
-Moi aussi, j'ai été bien élevée.
Mais heureusement,
parce qu'on est tous
des personnes humaines.
C'est la moindre des choses.
Je suis d'accord avec vous.
-On respecte les règles.
-Mme la présidente !
-Depuis le début du vote
à l'Assemblée,
vous fuyez.
-Je crois pas.
-Si.
La Macronie fuit la démocratie.
-Les organismes syndicaux
sont contre.
La majorité parlementaire
est contre.
Vous avez peur d'aller au vote.
Laissez aller jusqu'au vote.
C'est ça, le problème.
-Alors, pourquoi nous n'avons pas
voté la réforme des retraites
par un vote final
lorsqu'elle a été discutée
à l'Assemblée nationale ?
Pourquoi ?
-Vous avez eu peur.
-Mais non.
On a eu 20 000 amendements
qui ont fait
que nous n'avons pas pu débattre...
-C'est votre interprétation,
madame la présidente.
C'est gros comme le nez
au milieu du visage.
-Vous parlez de discuter,
mais vous ne nous écoutez pas.
Le pays, depuis le mois de janvier,
vous dit qu'il ne veut pas
de cette réforme.
-A chaque fois
que je fais un déplacement
et qu'il y a des délégations
de personnes qui veulent me parler,
je vais leur parler.
-On vous met en garde.
Une grosse fracture
avec les travailleurs,
les retraités et la jeunesse.
Vous ne vous rendez pas compte.
C'est très grave.
-A bientôt, au revoir.
-Au revoir.
-On tiendra, on tiendra.
Raffut de casseroles
...
-Un dialogue difficile.
-Après, ils veulent,
ils veulent pas,
mais ça permet au moins de...
-Mais un dialogue
nécessaire
pour la présidente de l'Assemblée.
-On a eu des échanges.
On n'est pas d'accord.
Il faut entendre la colère,
autrement, ça sert à rien,
si c'est juste leur parler
pour leur dire : "J'ai raison"...
Il faut entendre leur colère.
Il faut expliquer
pourquoi on a agi.
Là, on n'est pas rentrés
dans le fond des choses,
mais il ne faut jamais renoncer
à aller à la rencontre
et à essayer
de se comprendre mutuellement.
-Même si on ne convainc pas ?
-Même si on ne convainc pas,
c'est effectivement notre lot,
mais ne jamais renoncer.
Merci à vous.
-Changement de décor.
Le tour de la présidente
de l'Assemblée
s'arrête dans les Yvelines.
Yaël Braun-Pivet
vient parler démocratie.
*-Bonjour à tous.
*Je voudrais vous remercier
*de vous être rendus disponibles
pour ce temps d'échange.
*On peut parler du mode d'élection
du président de la République,
des députés,
*de la durée du mandat,
est-ce qu'il faut revenir
*à 7 ans,
est-ce qu'on reste à 5 ans ?
*Tous les sujets sont ouverts.
*A vous ! Monsieur.
*-Je pense que le 49.3
est à peu près
l'équivalent de l'édit royal
*d'il y a 300 ans, et ça,
c'est inadmissible.
Ne vous étonnez pas que les gens
*n'aillent plus voter
et qu'ils n'aient plus confiance.
Nos politiques nous trahissent.
*-La base, ce serait
de supprimer le 49.3.
*A part montrer à la population
que peu importe si elle se bat,
*si elle sort dans la rue,
si elle montre son mécontentement,
*eh bien, ce que le président
a décidé, c'est ce qui se fera,
donc, la base
est de supprimer le 49.3.
-Au procès du 49.3,
elle tente la pédagogie.
*-Je ne fais pas le lien
*entre confiance et 49.3,
mais peut-être fais-je erreur.
*Pourquoi on dit "49.3" ?
C'est un article de la constitution,
c'est un outil.
*Il a été conçu pour permettre
au gouvernement
de pouvoir continuer
*à mettre en oeuvre une politique
et de ne pas avoir
un blocage complet du pays.
Cet outil a un pendant,
*le Parlement peut mettre en jeu
la responsabilité
*du gouvernement en votant
une motion de censure.
*Quand le gouvernement
enclenche le 49.3,
il joue sa vie.
-Puis, chacun y va
de sa proposition.
-Allez-y. Monsieur.
*-J'ai jamais compris pourquoi
le vote électronique
n'a pas été mis en place.
*-Pour que les gens votent,
il faut qu'ils se sentent
représentés après l'élection.
Pour cela, il faut qu'il y ait
une dose de proportionnelle.
*-Sur la proportionnelle,
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez,
dans la salle ?
La proportionnelle,
on en parle beaucoup.
-La présidente reprend alors
ses réflexes de l'hémicycle.
*-Qui serait pour,
sans parler de dose, pas dose,
nationale, départementale ?
Juste sur le principe
de la proportionnelle,
qui est pour ?
-Intégrale ?
*-Peu importe,
intégrale, dose ou pas.
*Qui est contre ? Ah, ouais !
*Vous êtes un certain nombre
à vous être abstenus.
-Il y a chez ces habitants
des Mureaux une inquiétude.
Cette discussion va-t-elle
servir à quelque chose ?
*-J'ai une remarque.
*Ici, on a souvent
des visites de politiques.
Des gens viennent nous voir,
*mais après, le lien est rompu,
on sait pas ce qui se passe,
on sait pas si ce qu'on a dit
a eu un impact,
on sait pas si ce qu'on a pensé
*et ce qu'on a transmis
a été vraiment
*partagé et a eu du sens.
*-A quoi ça sert,
c'est une des questions,
et la jeune fille...
*Elle est là-bas !
"Ca fait plusieurs fois
qu'on voit des gens aux Mureaux,
"on sait pas à quoi ça sert."
*On n'a pas rédigé une constitution,
c'était pas l'objectif, là.
*Mais on a dit des choses.
*Ca ne veut pas dire
que les citoyens
sont décisionnaires,
mais ils alimentent nos réflexions.
*Donc, c'est à ça que ça sert.
-Pour réformer les institutions,
la présidente
de l'Assemblée nationale
consulte les groupes politiques,
mais elle veut surtout entendre
les citoyens.
-C'est effectivement
indispensable d'associer
les citoyens à cette réflexion,
puisque quand vous faites
de la politique,
vous la faites pour les gens.
Et donc, réformer notre vie
démocratique sans les Français
n'aurait juste aucun sens.
Et donc, avoir ce dialogue constant
lorsque je mène
ces consultations politiques
à l'Assemblée nationale,
avoir ce dialogue avec les Français
me semble incontournable.
-Redorer l'image de l'Assemblée,
rétablir la confiance
entre les Français et la politique,
Yaël Braun-Pivet le sait,
il faudra du temps pour y parvenir.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
Générique
...